bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter l'histoire de pierre pierre il
a une grande idée il a des capacités
il tient un concept et pourtant il ne
fait rien il ne fait rien parce qu'un
grand danger le guette le grand danger
le manque de temps or on a tous envie de
changer les choses
petites ou grandes et pourtant je suis
sûr que comme moi vous prononcez
régulièrement cette phrase je n'ai pas
le temps où je n'ai pas pris le temps
mon objectif aujourd'hui vous délivrer
trois clés ou prendre le temps d'aller
vite et aller au bout de vos idées
alors comment aider pierre bat pour
aider pierre on va d'abord jouer au jeu
de la balle le jeu de la balle c'est un
jeu simple ou des participants dans un
groupe se passe une balle de manière
aléatoire aléatoire ça veut dire que
chaque participant n'aura pas le droit
de passer la balle à son voisin et la
balle ne pourra passer que par un parti
participants je vais ensuite introduire
une notion de timing je vais des chronos
mitry au départ les participants restent
assis et sont principalement centrées
sur leurs performances individuelles
c'est à dire bien recevoir la balle bien
l'envoyer à la bonne personne
sur cette première phase les groupes
arrivent en moyenne à descendre leur
timing d'environ 30 me divisé par deux à
chaque fin de tour je pose la question
pensez vous pouvoir faire mieux un
certain moment le groupe me dit non on
peut pas faire mieux il ya toujours un
esprit avisé pour remettre en cause
l'organisation est proposé de se mettre
debout
on peut voir sur l'image de gauche qu'au
départ c'est un peu le chaos
les participants cherchent leur place
discute ça va consommer plusieurs
minutes pour trouver la bonne
organisation une fois que l'organisation
est mise en oeuvre très rapidement un
deux passages le temps est divisée par 3
c'est à dire qu'on passe de 45 à 15
secondes quand le temps est optimisé le
groupe
à la question pensez vous pouvoir faire
mieux pas de nouveau me répondre non un
participant propose toujours
systématiquement d'imaginer une façon de
travailler qu'il n'avait jamais pensé
cela remise en question des règles donc
avec ce groupe là là la stratégie qui a
été adoptée s'était posé le doigt sur la
balle j'ai vu plein de stratégies
différentes
la main de sous la main au dessus et
puis d'autres idées un peu plus à faire
feu ce qu'on peut retenir de cette
expérience et si on veut aider pierre
pierre ils doivent déjà se poser la
question dans quelle phase il est est ce
qu'il est dans la phase une où il doit
optimiser ses tâches individuelle est ce
qu'il est dans la phase 2 où il doit se
poser la question de la communication
avec les autres et de sa place dans
l'environnement de travail
il ya la gestion de l'espace dans cette
étape là est la question 3 6 est ce que
il doit imaginer une nouvelle façon de
travailler
la deuxième question à laquelle il faut
répondre ai-je optimiser mon temps si
oui je dois passer à l'étape suivante la
deuxième clé que je voulais vous
délivrer c'est la métaphore des grosses
pierres alors certains d'entre vous la
connaissent peut-être déjà c'est
l'histoire d'un conférencier qui place
successivement dans un bidon des grosses
pierres puis du gravier du sable et
enfin de long alors quand on parle de
gestion du temps on pourrait facilement
penser que cette métaphore sert à
montrer qu'il ya toujours un petit peu
de temps peut toujours caser quelque
chose de plus dans son emploi du temps
en réalité l'enseignement il est tout
autre l'enseignement est dit que ce qui
est important c'est l'ordre dans lequel
on place les choses c'est à dire que si
je passe pas les grosses pierres en
premier il y aura jamais la place de les
mettre
l'exemple il est simple si bidon je le
remplis d'eau au départ je peux plus
rien mettre dedans ça va déborder
donc en termes de gestion du temps il va
être important de définir ses priorités
pour bien définir ses priorités faut
distinguer les priorités de ce qu'on
appelle le flux l'aléa et l'urgence
alors je vais commencer par le flux le
flux c'est ce que vous faites tous les
jours quoiqu'il arrive pour vous le flux
c'est d'aller en cours pour moi le flux
c'est d'animer des formations on passe
aux aléas et aux urgences je prends un
exemple un gros client appelle dans
votre entreprise
il veut que vous réalisiez quelque chose
très rapidement pour là maintenant tout
de suite en général c'est la demande
urgent en soit les a alors la plupart du
temps d'entreprise
j'entends urgence c'est un gros client
donc c'est une urgence sur le plan
sémantique un l'urgence ça implique que
quelqu'un est blessé
ça implique que quelqu'un fait un
malaise ou ça implique qu'un incendie la
mairie d'annecy la semaine dernière oui
c'était l'urgence donc le gros clients
qui appellent et qui nous demande de
faire quelque chose très rapidement et
que c'est important
c'est un simple aléa en réalité la
différence en termes de gestion et
d'organisation du temps de travail c'est
que une urgence j'arrête tout ce que je
fais pour mettre dessus qu il veut
je me pose pas trop la question ce que
je termine ce que je suis en train de
faire alors qu'un aléa je peux terminer
ce que je suis en train de faire aller
jusqu'au bout et dont les 2 3 heures qui
arrivent donner réponse à mon client
alors si les priorités sont ni le flux
ni l'aléa et encore moins l'urgence
qu'est ce que c'est les priorités sont
des choses importantes
on prend pas toujours le temps de faire
des choses importantes qui vont me
permettre de faire mieux de faire plus
vite de diminuer le nombre d'aléas
ou alors de mettre en oeuvre des
nouvelles idées ou des nouveaux projets
ce que nous enseigne les lois du temps
et notamment la loi de pareto
c'est le fameux 80 c'est à dire que 80%
montant doit être dédiée sur la partie
bleue pour 20 % de mon temps dédié sur
la partie jaune les priorités en 20 % du
temps c'est quand même important
ça fait un peu moins de deux heures par
jour et ça fait une journée par semaine
comment placer sa danse non pas du temps
si je les place pas dès le départ c'est
pierre ne les placent pas dès le départ
si place pas son idée d'aller par il
pourra pas le mettre
la troisième clé que je souhaite vous
délivrer ses les ennemis il va falloir
les combattre il existe ce qu'on appelle
des voleurs de temps alors ghana des
internes et des experts je commençais
par les internes et le premier c'est le
perfectionnisme alors peut-être que vous
êtes dit pour répondre à la question
quels sont vos trois qualités vos trois
défauts pour préparer vos entretiens
d'embauché que ce serait une bonne idée
de mettre en haut de la tête de liste de
vos défauts le perfectionnisme en faut
savoir que perfectionnisme c'est un gros
vilains méchants défaut pourquoi parce
que quand un client ou une entreprise un
attendu qui est là quand je suis
perfectionniste je vais avoir un attendu
qui est là et ça veut dire que je vais
gaspiller du temps et des ressources qui
ne sont pas nécessaires c'est ce qu'on
appelle la sueur qualité donc pour le
perfectionnisme fait bien c'est déjà
très bien
le deuxième ennemis internes
c'est le pessimisme le pessimisme alors
il est plutôt lié aux aléas
quand quelque chose arrive dans la
journée qui était pas prévu j'ai deux
façons de traiter jeu peut râler me dire
que c'est pas normal et et perdre du
temps ou alors je peux traiter ça de
manière positive et de me dire ok ça
arrive c'est prévu dans mon agenda de
toute façon je sais rendent
l'imprévisible prévisible et du coup je
vais le faire et j'avance je perds pas
de temps
mon troisième ennemi interne je le nomme
la discussion réflexion la discussion
réflexion c'est quoi c'est prendre le
temps d'échanger de discuter et de
récolter de l'information de
s'interroger sur un sujet et de
réfléchir avant de passer à l'action
alors c'est très bien pour la partie
jaune par contre quand je suis dans le
flux ou les aléas il ya des méthodes
il ya des techniques il ya des
procédures je me pose pas de questions
je les applique
et comme ça je gagne du temps on passe
aux ennemis externe dans les ennemis
externe
celui qui est qui arrive en numéro 1
c'est le téléphone portable alors il
faut savoir que quand vous êtes en train
de faire quelque chose et que vous
prenez un quart de seconde pour regarder
l'heure sur votre téléphone portable
quand vous allez revenir sur votre tâche
initiale ce qui va se passer c'est qu'il
va y avoir un temps de concentration ou
est-ce que j'en étais qu'est ce que j'ai
déjà fait qu'est ce qu'il me reste à
faire ce temps de concentration il est
assez important donc si je suis en
permanence
switcher entre ma tâche et mon téléphone
portable je gaspille un temps qui est
très conséquent
vous devez vous autorisés à travailler
on voit des connectés c'est à dire le
téléphone il est comme aujourd'hui en
mode avion voir et un le reste du monde
continuera de vivre s'en fout le
deuxième fait au alors tout
particulièrement d'entreprise c'est le
mail faut savoir qu'un manager de
proximité il reçoit en moyenne entre 100
et 200 mails par jour ça représente 10
heures de travail par semaine en
traitement un jour et demi c'est énorme
les conseils qui sont donnés au tour du
mail c'est de les lire deux fois par
jour une fois le matin une fois l'après
midi ne pas les traiter au fil de l'eau
et de privilégier la voie du direct
c'est à dire que c'est pas un média de
communication efficace et vaut mieux
communiquer directement dans la vraie
vie plutôt que par m le mail va servir à
tracer l'information le troisième et
demie externe c'est l'environnement
direct les amis les collègues qui sont à
côté de nous quand nous sommes en train
de travailler
c'est un peu comme le téléphone ils vont
nous solliciter pour nous poser des
questions nous raconter leur week end
leurs vacances ce genre de choses donc
c'est assez sympa pour autant ça me
déconcentre alors c'est très compliqué
en d'appuyer sur un bouton et d'éteindre
son environnement extérieur
il existe des outils alors ya le casque
anti bruit quand quelqu'un porte en
général un casque on va moins le
solliciter si vous avez la possibilité
de travailler dans une pièce fermée
vous pouvez fermer la porte va vous
envoyer un signal fort je vais être
tranquille certains vont même jusqu'à
poser un écriteau séance de travail en
cours merci de revenir à partir de telle
heure ou alors le jeu de la
délocalisation c'est en train de se
développer en entreprise au travers du
home office home office ça consiste à
travailler chez soi
les taux de productivité en home office
monte jusqu'à 30%
tout simplement parce qu'on n'est pas
sollicitée par l'environnement extérieur
voilà pour les ennemis internes alors
concrètement si on veut aider pierre
comment il doit s'y prendre
eh ben tout d'abord il va placer ses
priorités dans son agenda
environ 20 % de son temps ensuite il va
y avoir le flux en le fus les plus ou
moins importants pour pouvoir le mesurer
ce flux il est conseillé de faire un
budget temps
je commence ma journée parce que j'aime
pas tout simplement parce que ce que
j'aime pas j'ai tendance à me
débarrasser aller vite et la deuxième
raison c'est que si j'aime pas et que je
garde pour la fin de journée
je risque de remettre à demain et
remettra demain on le sait tous et
remettra jamais après on va traiter les
mails deux fois par jour une fois le
matin une fois l'après midi il
conseillait le matin en même temps qu'on
traite les mails d'avoir une routine
alors au delà de boire le café dire
bonjour à ses collègues
l'objectif est d'organiser votre journée
de travail qu'est ce que j'ai à faire et
d'organiser votre espace de travail
parce que au bout d'un certain temps
l'efficacité des croix il est important
de faire des pauses au moins une le
matin et l'après-midi et une vraie pause
déjeuner les études montrent qu'au-delà
de entre 45 minutes et une une ou 1h30
nous sommes dans notre phase optimale de
concentration au delà d'une heure trente
à faire une pause après arrivent les
aléas
alors les aléas en fonction des métiers
en main certains groupes que j'ai
accompagné t à 30% d'aléas par jour
certaines activités on monte à 70 voire
80 % d'aléas comment rendre
l'imprévisible prévisible a tout
simplement se réservant du temps dans
son emploi du temps pour traiter les
aléas ce qui fait quand mon gros client
va m'appeler pour me dire j'ai besoin de
ça très rapidement très bien je le
traite aujourd'hui entre 11 heures et
midi
ça vous convient la réponse en général
oui puisque la proposition est tout à
fait raisonnable
pour terminer je vais finir ma journée
avec la routine du soir la routine du
soir consiste déjà arrangé son espace de
travail et l'ensemble des documents
traités dans la journée lors aussi bien
dans le monde réel que dans le monde
virtuel de manière à retrouver les
choses facilement et ne pas perdre de
temps à chercher
et puis terminer la journée par ce conte
elle tout simplement parce que ce qu'on
aime on a tendance à y passer un peu
plus de temps donc comme on a envie de
rentrer chez soi va peut-être pas le
faire et puis surtout bah je vais
combattre mon perfectionnisme parce que
je vais vouloir rentrer chez moi je vous
remercie pour votre attention et je vous
souhaite une journée pleine d'idées
[Applaudissements]